we'll get some random words and then
i'll freestyle rap about them then you
still seem very unconvinced
people over here what would you like a
rap about
my grandmother
on my on my mother's side of my father's
side
one of them's alive so choose wisely
mother's side correct well done
i mean i haven't checked the family
whatsapp in the last hour i don't know
also over there
it's like two in the morning so she
could have gone in asleep i hope not
fun fact often i'll put my my freestyle
wraps on the internet and i know my
grandmother subscribes to my youtube
channel and watches all of them and
shows them to her friends so hi grandma
um
i hope you've not gone in your sleep um
people over people over here what would
you like a ref about
tootsie rolls um
i i in the uk our candy is very
different to yours is that what type of
candy is that
lord knows
it's an evangelical candy strange
cool tootsie rolls the evangelical candy
and let's come to the kind of middle
like that people like on that side of
the room like the back of the room what
do you want a rapper
pardon
porn okay what um particular type of
pornography and let me say you you don't
have to
give me a real one you could make up a
category all of your own and you can say
you're being creative but actually we'll
all know that's your deepest darkest
fantasy
so just get get some adjectives and some
nouns smash them together that's the
type of pawn we're rapping about
that no that exists no i'm
that's that's where lots of men do a
spunk on a lady's face
no i want to create one that's gonna be
more fun
it's halloween let your evil minds run
right
double penetration exists come on
you could have been fun you could have
said hubble bubble penetration that
would have been better right let's let's
come up with it
no no
don't do my work for me
come on let's let's get some
sexy panda porn thank you and wait what
did you say over there
jailhouse chicks okay
yeah
sounds exploitative i mean we should
shut down rikers yes
so
my grandmother tootsie rolls the
evangelical candy either sexy panda porn
or jailhouse porn people over here what
would you like a rap about
a a wrinkle in time
that's it's that book that was then was
that the one that was adapted and kind
of sunk without a trace which yeah okay
a wrinkle in time never readable rapper
so my grandmother on my mother's side
sexy panda porn or jailhouse chicks
tootsie rolls evangelical candy and what
was that one from over here
the wrinkle in time of course yeah
no one else remembered that they were
just like
okay
well we'll start with that one um this
can be a freestyle rap man my lovely
band they're gonna drop a beat so let's
hear what we're gonna do let's see what
it's gonna be i'm excited you are so
tickled by this my lady down here uh
it's gonna be fun it's gonna be very fun
and let's do this nice cool
never ready but constructed thinking my
mind let me read the sci-fi book a
wrinkle in time probably aimed at the y
a young adult i've not read it but it's
not my fault it never took off in the uk
united kingdom if you got a local
library you should really bring them
some great books act like a smoothie the
librarians like they made this a movie
truly a fact i never went to see it was
whoopi goldberg in a year i think i'd
recall seeing on a poster a face maybe
i'm sure it had some other great acting
ladies and some kids probably acting
less when i'm in the jail yeah i like to
see the breasts i'm in the showers
looking at the gals undress i say oh
what's gonna happen next one getting
down on the knees giving gals a lick i'd
be like subscribing click jailhouse
chicks that's what i really like a
morning rub i want my jailhouse chicks
on the pornhub and that's jc that's the
acronym like jesus christ and you know
i'm adoring him i'm like oh to be as
good as you is my goal die for my sins
get a tootsie roll it's what i'm asking
yes i want to eat walking down the
street like a little ghost trick or
treat get into the house no reese's in
my mouth cause the tootsie roll is what
i'm truly about how many licks does it
take to get to the center maybe like
three or four yeah you know i meant to
lie to you i've actually ate one once it
was horrible i spat it out my mouth from
my bones on the floor i'm like i don't
understand you tasting candy but i like
the pandas oh over there makes me erect
when i see a little black and white bear
looking so sexy i don't want a brown one
or a grizzly i want the one from china
getting busy i see the little panda
gyrating and then he stands there
hesitating he's waiting why well
obviously you can d juice pandas really
struggle to reproduce they never get it
off when they're in captivity maybe get
the jailhouse panda proclivity who put
it on they start subscribing the panda
sees it he's like oh i'm arriving he's
got a low voice like he comes from
yorkshire it's where my grandmother's
from yes i talk to her directly like i'm
out of the camera i say hi there i love
you grandma you're cool even though your
hips break your knees weak i hope you're
still alive please don't go in your
sleep if you did everybody's panicking
they're like chris walter ryan's you're
managing to talk about this even though
she might be gone now she's great let me
take it back world war one she wasn't
alive then that would be so mental back
in the day she didn't have quinoa or
lentils she just ate flour she just ate
potatoes if she got a hole in her socks
then she'd done those reuse yeah a fact
we say this obviously she's old so
obviously she's racist and that's fine
before me she was born if she saw this
she'd be like chris what porn i'd have
to explain it she wouldn't understand i
say you sit down with a laptop on your
hand she says which one it doesn't
matter which hand's there and what do
you do click on jails or pandas this one
people getting into each other's dashes
there this one's at the zoo they make a
little baby it's really cute please best
panda sexy paws the one where it sneezed
[Applause]
you